CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
I work on graphics and
animations, and today I wanted
to talk a little
bit about that.
Specifically, I want to talk
about Value Animator and
Object Animator, and how you
can get different kinds of
movement on the screen.
So let's take a look
at a quick demo.
I call this "Bouncer." I have
my little electric sheep at
the top of the screen, and I
click on the screen, and a
sheep moves down, in a very
boring fashion, to the bottom
the screen.
Not much of a bounce, so let's
take a look at another
variation, which I call
"Bouncer One."
So we run bounder one, and now
we're actually going back up
to the top the screen, which
is a good start.
It's actually continuing to
move, which is kind of what
bouncing is about.
But it's got this weird, linear
oscillation thing going on.
So let's see if we can
do a little better.
We have this other variation,
which I call "Bouncer Two,"
and I can click that, and all
of a sudden, we've got a
bouncing motion.
So we'll see how we create that
with one line of code.
And finally, we've got this
other variation called
"Bouncer Three," which is
going to look remarkably
similar to bouncer two.
We've got the same bouncing,
gravity motion going on there.
The interesting part is in the
code, and how that one was
created using a different
kind of animator.
So let's look at the code now.
So we've got this bouncer file,
go up to the top of it.
You've got this activity called
"bouncer." We have a
custom view, where we're going
to be drawing this sheep, as
it moves around on the screen.
And here we have a set
up shape, where
we decode this resource.
So this is the electric sheep
thing that I spent hours and
hours drawing, because it's
such complex art.
We get the width and height of
this thing, to position it
appropriately later, so we can
center it in the screen.
As we change the position
properties of this sheep-- to
put it in the center of the
screen, or to move it down and
back up the screen during
the animations--
we call these setters, set
shape x and set shape y.
And this one basically figures
out-- the only reason there's
any complex code in here at
all is because we need to
invalidate the correct area,
so that we erase where the
sheep was, and then draw the
sheep in the correct area.
Otherwise, we're going to leave
litter artifacts all
over the screen, if we're
not a racing correctly.
Or, if we just do an invalidate
of the entire view,
then we're basically going to
be doing too much work,
because there's no reason to
erase the entire view, if all
you did was move the sheep
from here to here.
So we get the union rectangle,
and we invalidate
appropriately.
And we do this for both
of the setters here.
On Size Change, this allows
us to center the sheep
appropriately when the size
of the window changes.
And On Draw is where all of the
magic happens for actually
drawing the sheep
on the screen.
We simply draw the bit map at
the shape x and shape why
properties that were
set before.
For running the animation, we
have the Start Animation
method here, that gets called
when you click on the thing.
And we create a Value
Animator Object.
And this is one of the new
classes that was created in
the 3.0 release, part of an
overall, more robust timing
and animation engine.
Value animation animator is
basically the timing, the meat
of the entire animation
package.
It's the timing engine behind
Object Animator, Animator Set,
and View Property Animator, and
we'll see all of these in
future episodes.
And all it is, is a timing
mechanism, a timing and value
calculation mechanism.
Doesn't know about views,
doesn't know
about objects at all.
All it knows how to do is to
calculate values, based on
parameters that you give it
for the start and the end
values, as well as durations,
and other properties which
we'll see today.
So we create this value
animator by
calling Get Value Animator.
This comes down here and says
Value Animator.offloat, and
this is going to calculate
animation values between a
starting value of zero, and
an ending value of one.
And then we add an
update listener.
And if you use Value Animator,
which is a more manual way of
doing an animation, then you
probably want to have an
update listener.
And that's will get called on
every frame in the animation,
and then you can do whatever you
want to with the values.
So every time we get a call--
let me reposition this code
a little bit, so you can
actually see it on
the screen--
on Animation Update, we get a
reference to the animation
object itself.
And then we can get the animated
fraction, so we can
find out between value of zero
and one, what is the current
animation fraction?
And we could also get the
animated value at
that time if we wanted.
Here, we're just going between
zero and one, it doesn't
really matter.
And we basically use that
animation fraction, between
zero and one, to affect the
height of the sheep.
So we basically want to move the
sheep from the top of the
screen, down to the bottom of
the screen, minus the height
of the sheep.
So we're going to take the zero
and one factors that we
get during the animation itself,
and simply apply that
directly as a proportion
of the height at which
the sheep is drawn.
And that's all to bouncer.
So it gets a little bit more
interesting once we start
adding actual bouncing
capabilities.
All this one does is animate the
thing down to the bottom
of the screen in a very
boring fashion.
Bouncer one is a way to do
that with a little bit of
repetition.
This is the one that oscillated
down to the bottom
of the screen and
then back up.
So here, we get Value
Animator, same
exact thing going on.
But we also set a repeat count
of infinite, which means it's
just going to repeat until you
finally quit the application
because it's not very
interesting.
And it's also going to set a
repeat mode reverse, so when
it reaches the bottom,
it's going to
animate back up to one.
Internally, what that means is
the Value Animator is going to
run from zero to one, and then
back to zero, and ad
infinitum, until you kill
the application.
Then we start the animation.
That was the second animation.
The third one was
the one where it
was actually bouncing.
It was speeding up as it fell
down, and then it slowed down
as it went back up, sort of
a gravity motion to it.
So that logic is in the bouncer
two file, and it's
exactly like the previous one we
looked at, except for this
one line of code where we
set an interpolator.
An interpolator you can
think of as a way of
re-interpreting time.
And by reinterpreting time, we
also reinterpret how the
values are calculated,
because those are
based on the time value.
So here we're saying, use an
accelerate interpolator, which
means the longer you go the
faster you're going to get.
But then, interestingly, when it
reverses, it's going to use
the interpolator in reverse.
So it's going to speed up on the
way down to one, and then
it's going to slow down
back up to zero.
And that's how we get the
bouncing behavior, as we go
down and up the screen.
And then finally, we can take
a look at the bouncer three
file, which produced exactly
the same visual result, but
with a little less code.
This gets into use of the new
Object Animator class that
also came out in 3.0.
And this is a class that's
specifically not just about
animating values, but about
animating the values on a
target object and set
a target properties.
In particular, we're going to
have an object animator--
which is created right here--
that's going to animate
integer values.
It's going to use this target,
which is the custom view.
And we're going to animate the
"shape Y" property, which is
just a string that we're passing
in, which will then
use reflection or JNI underneath
to say, given this
string name, is there a setter
of this type that I can
associate with this, and
then call that setter
over time to animate.
And in fact, it does find that,
because we have the set
shape y setter that
we saw earlier.
And it's going to animate that
property from the value of
zero to the maximum value.
So you can compare this to what
we saw before where we
created the value animator, and
then we needed to use an
update listener to actually
use that value over time.
Object animator does
that all for you.
You point it at the target
object to animate, the
properties in that object
to animate, and
the values to use.
Then you simply start the
animation, and away it goes.
It calculates the values, it
sets it on the target object,
and it's basically a set
and forget thing.
You create the animation, you
run it, and you're done.
So this was a little bit about
the Property Animation system
that started in 3.0.
So if you're running devices
with 3.0, I would suggest you
take a look at these classes,
in addition to the View
Property Animator class, which
we'll see in a future episode.
Thanks.